c'est vrai qu'on a fait beaucoup de
choses ensemble en politique mais on
était d'abord amis chagra est hélas
l'immense immense mais paul est marqué
de façon extraordinaire extraordinaire
la vie politique d'abord parce qu'elle
était toute tendue vers les autres et
vers les plus petits les plus faibles
les plus fragiles
petit à petit c'est la cause des
personnes âgées qui a été la grande
cause de sa vie mais depuis toujours
c'est la cause des plus faibles à côté
des personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées le handicap mental s'est
battu aussi pour faire reconnaître le
handicap mental handicap psychique comme
une maladie et puis les petits à ces
temps ci avec toute la crise du coc vide
elle me parlait sans arrêt des petits
commerces des petits artisans les petits
les petits et puis justement elle s'est
toujours mis à là à la hauteur des
petits avec des mots simples
authentiques
elle était naturelle c'était une figure
unique
c'était une figure unique dont je veux
dire que dans le chagrin
cette figure authentique naturel simple
et tellement efficace parce qu'elle a
transformé des politiques publiques la
politique publique en direction du grand
âge elle l'a transformé
donc elle a été une ambassadrice de la
politique de façon extraordinaire et
l'énergie aie la détermination qu'elle a
mis partout dans tout ce qu'elle a fait
est là je peux vous dire ce matin
l'énergie et la détermination qu'elle a
mise jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout elle
avait une maladie héréditaire son papa
mais vu la même maladie elle savait ce
qui l'attendait un corps complètement
qu'il a lâché complètement alors que sa
tête ne la lâchait pas sa source
c'était terrible terrible et du coup
elle a décidé elle a décidé de partir et
elle a voulu que ce geste soit connue en
pensant que ça pouvait peut-être être
une contribution au débat public en
france qui s'entame serez entame se
ferme se rouvrent n'arrive pas à avancer
sur ce sujet est compliqué c'est vrai
elle même n'était pas adepte de ce qu'on
appelle le suicide assisté
les circonstances de la vie l'ont amenée
et elle a souhaité qu effectivement ce
geste soit connue pour qu' il puisse
compter dans les débats à venir sur la
fin de vie oui non elle m'a pas demandé
ça à moi mais dans les derniers jours de
sa vie elle a demandé à ce que ce soit
là elle a dit qu'il fallait que ce soit
public que ce soit connue que ce ne soit
pas caché pour que ça soit contributif
au débat elle l'a dit à son mari
mais ce choix lui appartient je réagis
en dix ans
jusqu'au bout elle a été une femme libre
une femme déterminée
maîtrisant son destin pour elle la vie
compter jusqu'au bout malgré toutes les
souffrances qu'elles avaient elles nous
accueillait avec le sourire dans la vie
elle s'est intéressée jusqu'au dernier
moment à toute l'actualité ou du monde
entier elle lisait les mémoires d'obama
en ce moment elles étaient tous tendus
vers tout ce qui fait débat dans notre
société
mais son corps ne répondait plus
son corps ne répondait plus elle nous
laisse une grande grande leçon de
grande leçon de vie à tous ceux qui
l'ont aimée je sais qu'ils sont nombreux
jeudi jusqu'au bout elle a entretenu la
flamme de la vie jusqu'au bout est ce
cette phrase qu'on l'a souvent entendu
dire peu importe la longueur de la
bougie ce qui compte c'est la flamme
dans quai de la flamme il ya de la vie
jusqu'à hier soir elle était dans la vie
puis ce matin à la bascule est ce que la
souffrance était insupportable
donc c'est respect c'est respect et cpl